thank you very much for joining us we
begin this newshour in ethiopia where
the conflict between the government and
tigray rebels is escalating prime
minister abby ahmed has now left the
capital addis ababa and is heading to
the front line to lead his troops in
battle
it comes just hours after the united
nations ordered the immediate evacuation
of its international staff
the presidents of kenya and south africa
have both called for a ceasefire in a
moment we'll be speaking to journalist
sameel getachu in addis ababa but
victoria gatenbee begins our coverage
with this report
some of prime ministers
soldiers are now prisoners of war and
the tigrans have been parading them
before the cameras
the presidents of kenya and south africa
say all parties must commit to ending
the violence
we expressed our conviction that there
is scope for dialogue
amongst the warring parties in ethiopia
and that there is an urgent need for all
parties to the conflict
to commit to an immediate
indefinite
and negotiated cease-fire
and that all inclusive political
dialogue
as the war draws closer to the ethiopian
capital plans to defend addis ababa are
intensifying these women have joined a
neighborhood protection force to guard
against advancing rebel forces they've
set up roadblocks are searching vehicles
for weapons and are checking people's
documents
we women believe that random security
checks and passes by are very important
we also encourage others to do the same
because when we do this we have no doubt
that strangers will be caught
[Music]
abby has informed the nation that he's
going to the front line where he'll
personally lead the army and he's asked
the ethiopians to join him in what he
calls the battle to save the nation
the u.s is calling the military
escalation alarming and says it
threatens any diplomatic progress
between the government and to graham
forces addis is under great threat
and it also means that there's likely to
be considerably more suffering and
people should leave now
to avoid
the worst possible scenario which could
be
rebel forces entering addis or
starvation or
deprivation
germany and france have joined the us in
urging their citizens to leave ethiopia
while the un says it's temporarily
relocating the families of its staff
meanwhile more than 2 million ethiopians
have now fled their homes with reports
of human rights abuses on both sides and
7 million people are in need of food aid
victoria gatenbee al jazeera
well let's take a look at where the
fighting is happening in ethiopia the
tplf rebels are pushing south from
tigray into the neighboring regions of
amhara and afar and down a major road
running to the capital addis ababa
tigran rebels said earlier this month
they've taken control of these two towns
kombolcha sits on a supply line linking
the landlocked nation to the port city
of djibouti last week the rebels claimed
to have captured the northern town of
shira rabbit about 200 kilometers from
the capital addis alba
let's get the latest now from
journalists samuel getachu who joins us
live from addis so samuel on tuesday
prime minister abby ahmed had announced
that he would go to the front line
what's the latest you're hearing about
his movements
well the head of government
communications
toulou has confirmed that the prime
minister is indeed in the battleground
uh making sure that
from their perspective that they would
be in a position to defeat the tplf that
has been advancing to the capital in the
last few weeks
uh the
the price it was also announced that the
power of uh
of his office would be transferred to
his deputy democrat a long-time deputy
of uh the prime minister who really
supported him when he became prime
minister taking his uh ambition aside
and
endorsing his candidacy
and having him become prime minister but
this comes as this conflict is really
impacting uh so many people the french
the turkish and many many countries
including the un personnels and their
dependents have been asked to to leave
ethiopia fearing that the u.n by the u.n
that the conflict is coming to a home
stretch and it will be affecting them
in the coming very soon indeed there is
growing international concern and as you
say a number of countries now asking
their citizens to leave ethiopia just
coming back to the president's uh
messaging and you know the fact that
he's now going to the front line himself
he's clearly trying to rally support and
perhaps to get ethiopians to join in
this war effort how are they reacting to
this will will they heed his call to
join the war effort
well this past weekend there were
thousands and thousands of ethiopians
around the world who came out in support
of the prime minister saying that they
don't want to be uh having a tplf
uh anywhere near addis ababa he's been
getting more resources from uh
ethiopians living abroad and even in
addis ababa the famous olympian uh
gabriel
is saying that he's ready to go and
join the prime minister in in this
conflict there are many many young
people that are signing up uh to see
that this conflict will be won by the
ethiopian side
but again there has been many many
efforts to end this conflict in a more
peaceful way the u.s envoy was just in
town trying to speak to different actors
he has said that the more the tpnf is
nearing the capital their expectation
and their demands are just increasing to
a point that it's becoming impossible to
solve this conflict yeah it doesn't look
like a negotiated settlement can be
reached anytime soon samuel i i know
it's been very difficult to get
information accurate reliable
information about what's happening on
the front line about the conflict
from from what you've been observing in
the past few weeks and past few months
who do you think has the upper hand
right now there's of course word that
the tplf are nearing addis and so on but
do you get a sense that you know they
have the upper hand right now in this
conflict
well they're shown a very strength uh in
the last few months and that's why the
ethiopian side is alleging that they're
being supported by either the u.s
or even by the u.n agencies
there's a mainstream accusation not just
by the government by
my by many ethiopians that
all these western nations are in support
of the tplf and there is a movement now
saying no more of western nations having
influence in ethiopia because many
people are insisting that this is an
ethiopian issue that
should be solved by ethiopians uh
something that captures the essence of
uh the african indian
legacy of african problem african
solution that has been promoted in the
continent but the ethiopian side is also
recruiting many people um you know
there's resources that's coming from
within and from outside uh ethiopia by
ethiopia and diasporas so they're both
getting all the support they can but
again there's a fear uh ethiopia and the
state of uh the state of emergency is
really having an impact on the ground
there are many people that are being
detained accused of
siding or supporting directly or
indirectly of the tplf which the
ethiopian side is suggesting is a
terrorist organization
samuel thank you so much for that update
samuel getachu ethiopian journalist
joining us there from uh the capital
addis ababa with the latest on the
situation there